bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors cette émission c'est pas
tellement pour vous annoncer des news
parce que je pense pas que vous ayez pu
passer à côté de ce dont je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui
par contre ça va être d'amener un petit
peu de nuances dans ce qui a pu être dit
et y compris ce qu'on a pu dire sur
cette chaîne
d'apporter un petit peu de nuances sur
des actualités et notamment sur ses
actualités brûlantes est toute fraîche à
propos des ze de dinosaures à coki molle
et aussi à propos de spinosaurus voilà
donc il ya des choses qui ont été dites
sur sur les médias sur internet
et comme je les dis sur cette chaîne et
on va essayer de un petit peu de nuances
et tout ça parce qu'évidemment la
science c'est aussi une discipline qui
demande de la nuance et qui demande
aussi de d'attendre un petit peu de
prendre du recul sur les effets
d'annoncé pour voir aussi quel genre de
contestation va dire ou quel genre de
débats peuvent émerger de certains effet
d'annonce donc l'annoncent la plus
récente la plus fraîche et certainement
la plus percutante qui a été fait
récemment celle annonce que les
dinosaures avaient une coquille molle
donc c'est en fait celle annonce surtout
que la raison pour laquelle on trouve si
peu d'oeuf de dinosaures c'est
principalement parce que les dinosaures
en tout cas la plupart des dinosaures
aurais-tu une coquille molle alors c'est
une annonce qui a été faite dans le
journal nature's par une équipe qui
comprend yasmin avait vman et si si vous
suivez pas les eaux news vous avez vu
que yasmina vman c'est aussi elle qui a
qui a réussi à d a retrouvé à
reconstituer des protéines qui sont
vieilles de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'années c'est à dire qu'elle
n'a pas seulement découvert des
protéines comme l'a fait schweitzer dans
d autres dinosaures de 65 millions
d'années
enfin de 70 millions d'années ll a
réussi à retrouver des protéines presque
détruite elle a réussi avec un processus
un processus auquel je ne comprends pas
grand chose à reconstituer ces protéines
avec une précision qui semble avoisiner
les 60% en tout cas à l'époque où elle a
fait sa présentation à la société de
paléontologie des vertébrés c'est à dire
l'année dernière déjà elle avait l'air
d'avoir atteint une précision de 60 % ce
qui est remarquable étant donné que
c'est pas des protéines dans l'état où
elles sont découvertes c'est des
protéines reconstituer et pour sa
l'utilisent la spectroscopie
spectroscopie raman air à m
à n est certes spectroscopie raman cette
fois lui a permis d'étudier des oeufs de
dinosaures et notamment la coquille
molle de certains oeufs de dinosaures
ici proto ceratops donc le cera tokia et
musso russe qui est un pro sauropodes un
sauropodomorphes basale donc voilà c'est
cette équipe là un qui a fait ce travail
donc a priori quelque chose de quelque
chose qui utilise une technique nouvelle
mais qui se tient quand même
est ce qu'ils ont découvert du coup ben
c'est que déjà les musées russes donc à
une coquille qui est effectivement molle
ça on le savait c'est pas une non plus
une surprise mais cette coquille donc à
des particularités chimiques qui la
rapproche d'une coquille à membrane web
globalement on va peut-être aller voir
une des figures ça va aller ça va être
plus simple d'en parler si on regarde
les figures de l'article directement
donc en gros il ya deux types de
protéines qu'ils ont découverte
enfin oui qu'ils ont découverte en
utilisant leur spectroscopie il ya les
dinosaures qui ont une des protéines qui
est que l'on trouve dans les zones
minéralisées qui sont ici en rose
pourpre
tout dépend si vous êtes daltoniens ou
pas et vous avez ici les protéines qui
sont découvertes dans les zones
minéralisées qui sont en bleu est il ce
qu'ils ont découvert c'est que proto
ceratops ici et musso russe ici ils sont
plutôt du côté des bestioles qui ont des
protéines qui correspondent à des oeufs
non bio minéralisées alors que
certains autres dinosaures donc les
titanosaures les titanosaures c'est les
gros ce qu'on trouve dans le sud de la
france par exemple les trop d'entités et
puis évidemment les oiseaux ils ont des
yeux qui sont plutôt minéralisée
fortement minéralisées et mahias aura
d'ailleurs les oeufs de maya saura tombe
aussi du côté déminéralisée donc c'est
vu comme ça ça n'a pas l'air d'être
grand chose voilà pour dire les choses
pour dire les choses simplement vu comme
ça ça fait pas rêver je veux dire ça
voilà il ya des dinosaures qui tombe
côté minéralisée des dinosaures qui
tombe côté pas minéralisées mais quand
on replace s'assure une phylogénie et
bien ça vous donne un résultat
intéressant puisque ça vous donne que en
fait vous avez donc effectivement dea
koki minéralisées du côté on it is tient
du côté sort ischia mais vous avez aussi
des oeufs non minéralisés de chaque côté
et une reconstitution de caractère
ancestral donc qui se fait c'est dans
les files au génie quand on utilise les
caractères pour retourner pour
reconstituer une phylogénie on peut pas
faire une reconstitution de caractère
ancestral par contre quand on connaît
déjà la phylogénie et qu'on veut voir
l'évolution des caractères à travers
cette phylogénie là on peut reconstituer
les caractères ancestraux on peut dire
bah voilà ici c'est plus probable que la
coquille soit plutôt non minéralisée
puisque là vous voyez les espèces qui
ont une coquille non minéralisées sont
plus basale et plus ancien musée russe
et ma sauce pon di luce qui ont des
coquines on minéralisées sont sont des
dinosaures plutôt des sauropodomorphes
plutôt bazzo c'est des pros sauropodes
et ils sont plutôt ancien et date du
trias donc ils sont beaucoup plus il est
beaucoup plus probable que l' état
ancestral ressemble à ces pots
sauropodomorphes du côté des sceaux
risque un que à ses cadets titanosaures
qui datent du crétacé et qui sont donc
beaucoup plus dérivés et pareil pour les
pareil pour les
les théropodes ici c'est tous des
théropodes relativement dérivés tout ça
et là on a des ornithologues du crétacé
versus des soeurs at obtient en face du
crétacé supérieur versus dessert
adoption du crétacé plutôt inférieures
bien qu'il soit plus d arriver dans
l'arbre mais bon le caractère ancestral
pour tous les dinosaures apparemment il
est reconstruit comme nous ici en bleu
membrane plutôt membraneux et pas
beaucoup de calcite donc plutôt oeuf
nous et tout ça est évidemment très
dépendant aussi de qui on place en
groupes externes parce que si le groupe
frère des dinosaures là il a les oeufs
durs
phaléne aco qui durent bas ici on risque
de retrouver quand même dea quo qui dure
qui ont été ensuite se transformer en
neuf à coki mou mais le groupe frère des
dinosaures pour qui on a des oeuf des
oeufs fossilisés c'est les ptérosaures
des ptérosaures qui sont plus proches
des dinosaures que ne le sont les
crocodiles les crocodiles ont des oeufs
durs les ptérosaures ont des yeux me
quoique non en fait je dis peut-être des
bêtises allons voir on allait donner
devant les yeux alors on peut aller
vérifier c'est ça qui est bien non les
crocodiles idée les crocodiles parement
ils ont plutôt des coquilles des
coquilles molle
ils sont plutôt qu'aux qui molle donc
non non tout à fait autant pour moi
les crocodiles ils ont plutôt des
coquilles molle donc on a les deux
groupes frères des dinosaures qui ont
des yeux à coki molle donc le l'état
ancestrale reconstituer des dinosaures
c'est la coquille molle et c'est comme
ça qu'on arrive à ce résultat c'est
parce qu'on a des oeufs de ptérosaure
qui viennent de chine et qui sont à coki
molle on le sait qu'ils sont à coke
immeuble parce que la coupe parce que le
fossile montre une coquille tout ramolli
tout simplement
et puis on connaît l'état chez les
crocodiles moderne alors ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant du coup c'est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant du coup c'est que ça
explique pourquoi on ne trouve pas de
neuf de dinosaure dans le trias et le
jurassique les premiers 10e de
dinosaures qu'on trouve en tout cas très
abondants c'est plutôt ancré d'assez ou
à la toute fin du jurassique
éventuellement mais pas avant ça donc ça
expliquerait du coup pourquoi on n'en
trouve pas avant et que les seuls ceux
qu'on trouve ce sont ceux de ma sauce
pondi lui ces deux musées russes dans le
g10 le trias tout à l'heure c'est le
début du jura si contents pour moi donc
les seuls ceux qu'on retrouve de
dinosaures au début du jurassique
c'est ceux de ma sauce pondi lucet musso
russe et c'est parce qu'on trouve des
embryons dedans qu'on sait que c d e
parce que votre en rolls on n'en saurait
rien ce serait des nodules et enfin des
concrétions et on serait pas trop quoi
en faire quoi donc là c'est bien parce
qu'on trouve des oeufs des embryons
dedans qu'on sait que c d e
donc voilà ça résout un petit mystère
mais ce qui encore une fois le but de
cette vidéo c'est d'apporter un peu de
nuance et la nuance apportée à ça c'est
une nuance qui m'a été soulignée par par
mon collègue lucas legendre dans cette
interview que j'ai fait de lui il ya
quelques jours à propos du prochain
article qu'on va traiter
donc voilà je vous mets le lien dans la
description jeu mais la petite image
dans le coin 7 ce qui nous a dit c'est
que c'est très dépendants des espèces
qu'on y inclus à cette fille au génie
parce que si vous regardez le nombre de
deux des espèces qu'on a en bout de
branche là pour reconstituer l'état
ancestrale il y en a pas des masses y en
a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
voilà donc c'est pas c'est pas beaucoup
c'est pas beaucoup et donc par exemple
comme je le disais découvrir ici par
exemple que les si les eaux rider avait
en fait des oeufs durs bas ça vous
change complètement l'état ancestrale
des dinosaures du mois ça rajoute une
ambiguïté assez monumentale
si on découvre soudainement que les
hétéros d'autorité avait aussi des oeufs
durs ça veut dire que les ornithischiens
l'ancêtre commun avait aussi des oeufs
aco qui durent donc c'est très très
dépendants de ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur en fait de ce groupe d de
ceux de ce qu'on appelle link group ici
le groupe interne et aussi ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
utilisé le l'arbre des ornithos élida
parce que si on met les sauropodes à la
base et les ornithischiens et les sons
risque ya en haut c'est pareil ça
les ornithischiens et les théropodes en
eau ensemble et bah ça risque de changer
aussi pas mal de choses là en
l'occurrence ça rapproche
ma sauce pondi lucet musso russe de la
base des dinosaures donc au final ça
finira quand même en 9 me mais par
contre on découvrirait peut-être que
l'ours être d ornithologie davud kylie a
surtout des espèces à coki dur à
l'intérieur
vu tous les théropodes ont une coquille
dur et il ya les en it aux potes qui ont
la cote qui durera peut-être que
l'ancêtre des ornitho série dallas par
contre il aurait une coquille molle donc
on n'aurait pas besoin peut-être d'avoir
trois transformations vers dea quo qui
dure parce que c'est aussi ça le l'autre
l'autre chose qui est importante dans
cet article ça veut dire que si on part
d'une coquille molle il faut une deux et
trois transformations une chez les
théropodes une chez les maquereaux
narnia c'est à dire les sauropodes et
une chez les ornithologues pour obtenir
le registre fossile qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
et si on change ça si on considère les
en italie il a peut-être qu'on aurait
besoin que de deux transformations une
chez les sauropodes et une chez les
ornithos élida mais bon voilà donc c'est
juste pour vous dire que il faut mettre
un petit peu de nuances là dedans il
faut voir que cette technique de
reconstitution de caractère ancestral
est très dépendante de la phylogénie et
que donc il pas impossible que regret
des futures découvertes et notamment de
ce qui se passera chez césar need is
kill bazzo et pourquoi pas chez les
théropodes bazzo on va pouvoir confirmer
ou infirmer l'hypothèse que l'ancêtre
des dinosaures avaient des e books est
justement en parlant de flou c'est
l'heure de parler de ceux d'un oeuf
géant du crétacé d'antarctique à neuf
géants aco ki moon qui a été découvert
donc temps
dans la toute fin du crétacé et qui a
vouvoyé ressemble à ça c'est une grosse
crotte de nez c'est une immense crottes
de nez de la taille d'un ballon de rugby
et cette crotte de nez et bien quand on
regarde sa structure microscopique on
voit que en fait il ya une coquille
dessus elle est très très fine très une
coquille très très très fine
mais du coup ça fait de ce truc 1,9 ça
il n'y a pas de doute là dessus c'est
bel et bien un oeuf et les grosses
critiques qui a eu par rapport à ça
c'est par rapport à son identification
puisque évidemment s'il n'y a pas dans
bryant à l'intérieur et s'il n'y a pas
une maman fossilisés autour globalement
c'est pas très facile d'identifier le
propriétaire de cet oeuf et donc les
auteurs se sont arrêtés sur un mot à
tort ou possiblement un plésiosaure avec
une préférence très nette pour le mot
hasard puisque toutes leurs
communications dans toutes les
communications qu'ils ont fait les
images qu'ils ont communiqué c'est des
images de mozart donc il ya une très
nette préférence pour l'hypothèse mozart
yens préférence qui est motivée
essentiellement parce qu'on a découvert
en australie un plésiosaure qui qui
possède un embryon dans son ventre
embryons qui est tout seul
relativement développés
et donc c'est très il ya très très peu
de chances qu'un embryon de qu'un gros
embryons se retrouve dans un oeuf à
l'intérieur du ventre de la mère c'est
plus probable que cet embryon et été et
été accouché de façon vive ipar pa
ovipare donc ça c'est donc ça c'est pour
les plésiosaures on a fait ça pour les
plésiosaures on a un spécimen c'est pas
non plus la panacée mais bon c'est un
spécimen qui nous donne un point
d'ancrage solide qui nous dit bon gars
si les plésiosaures pondent des oeufs
ils pondent est quand même de vachement
bronze avec des embryons bien développé
dedans donc c'est plus probable quand
même que c'était comme chez les dauphins
voilà ont donné naissance à un petit qui
va nager très vite qui sort la tête la
première qui va nager vers la surface
pour respirer
c'est pareil pour les ichthyosaures les
ichtyosaures on appareil c'est ces
mamans fossilisés en train d'accoucher
un embryon bon en train d'accoucher
pardon à un foetus est donc ce bébé là
il va quantinet c'est pareil il essore
la tête la première il va nager vers la
surface du moins c'est ce qu'on pense
bon j'ai encore une fois la dernière
fois j'ai mis de la nuance sur ses
interprétations en disant que s'ils sont
morts en s'ils sont morts comme ça c'est
probablement qu'ils étaient très mauvais
c'est aussi peut-être parce qu'ils
étaient très mauvais quand ils le
faisaient
voilà si vous êtes mort en train
d'accoucher c'est que vous êtes
probablement pas bon a accouché mais bon
on va dire que on va dire que
l'hypothèse la plus parcimonieux c'est
quand même que ce qui est fossilisés est
la moyenne
voilà donc si on fossilise amour 1
comportement d'accouchement une biologie
vivipare c'est que la biologie vivipare
était plus communes que la biologie pas
vivipare donc bon on fait des paris
je veux dire et c'est ça qu'il faut bien
reconnaître c'est que heu là ils font le
pari que c'est plutôt du mozart parce
qu'il trouvent du mozart sur place parce
qu'ils vont ils ont aussi trouvé du
plaisir aux orres ceci étant dit et
surtout l'argument massue on va dire
pour l'identification que cette âme aux
açores c'est que la structure de la
coquille est extrêmement similaire à
certains squamates donc les squamates ce
sont les lézards et les reptiles etc les
ce sont les lézards et les serpents
pardon parce que les arts et les
reptiles ça ne veut rien dire donc les
lézards et les serpents et il se trouve
que les mosasaures ne sont jamais ni
plus ni moins que des warrants c'était
c'est des gros varan qui nagent les mots
adore tous dans leur anatomie vient du
warrant je dire tout comparer un crâne
de mozart un crâne de varans de komodo
il ya assez peu de différence au final
donc tous dans leur anatomie creeks et
du warrant et tout le monde est assez
d'accord pour dire que c'est du vent
alors après il ya du débat pour dire si
les cils sont plus proches des warrants
ou s'ils sont les ancêtres des serpents
la vérité c'est que les warrants sont
pas non plus il éloigné de si éloigné
des serpents puisqu'ils ont cette
fameuse langue crochus la langue en
fourchette avec deux pointes
les warrants comme les serpents donc
c'est probablement hérité d'un ancêtre
en commun donc c'est possible que les
mosasaures face le pont entre les deux
au final mais bref il ya un débat autour
de ça mais c'est pas le c'est
complètement
c'est complètement anecdotique dans le
cas de ceux de cet article ça veut juste
dire que voilà la morphologie de la
coquille retrouver chez cet oeuf est
typiquement celle d'un squamates et les
plésiosaures ne sont pas des squamates
tout au plus les plésiosaures seraient
placés dans l'épi de zorro morph
c'est-à-dire à l'extérieur des squamates
à l'extérieur du ce fait nos dons donc
du toit tara donc on serait vraiment à
la toute base voilà les les pizzerias
les squamates en gros
si je me trompe pas ce serait là ce
serait ces bêtes là les squamates avec
la coquille très très fine
voilà vers les bleus donc la copie très
très fine ce serait les squamates et en
gros les les plésiosaures brancherait
quelque part par là à quoi veut dire
complètement à l'extérieur du des
squames à quoi et quand on sort plus on
va vers l'extérieur des squamates et
plus la coquille et dur d'ailleurs on
remarquera que les dinosaures dans
l'eure dans leur analyse donc c'est à
dire tout ce beau monde là plus là les
oiseaux à la base ils sont plutôt
reconstruit avec une coquille moyens mou
donc ils trouvent un résultat justement
comme le disait légèrement différent
parce qu'ils ont un échantillonnage
aussi qui est un peu différent c'est à
dire que ils ont considéré les
ptérosaures comme groupes externes
ils ont aussi considéré tout un tas
d'autres groupes externes que les
ptérosaures les crocodiles ils ont aussi
inclus les tortues sont aussi acculé les
pi 2 or donc ça influe évidemment sur le
résultat sur la reconstitution de
caractère ancestral
je pense qu'ils ont aussi utilisé une
autre technique basée sur une méthode
bayésienne si je ne m'abuse mais
faudrait que j'aille vérifier dans les
matériels méthodes mais bref voilà c'est
juste pour vous montrer que là pour le
coup ce parmi les lipides aux orres ceux
qui ont la coquine la coke est la plus
fine les eaux les plus mous ce sont les
escouades donc ça colle mieux avec les
squamates qu'avec les plésiosaures qu'on
s'imagine par ici plus tôt donc ça c'est
les arguments pour dire que c'est du
c'est plutôt du mozart mais évidemment
il ya des gens pour pour le contester
et notamment à la lumière de cet article
si un puisque là on dit les dinosaures
ont des zones où donc pourquoi ce ne
serait pas des oeufs de dinosaures
choses qui l'ont exclu justement en
disant que les oeufs de dinosaures
même en reconstituant leur caractère
ancestraux n'aurait pas une coquille
aussi fine que ça c'est ce qu'ils disent
ici donc eux c'est leur argument eux
selon leur reconstitution a eu les
dinosaures ne devrait pas avoir une
coquille aussi fine mai
mais bon c'est voilà il ya quand même un
article qui dit le contraire donc déjà
ça faut pas l'ignorer mais deuxièmement
ce qu'il faut prendre en compte c'est le
fait qu'on sait pas pour l'instant s'il
est on sait pas si les mosasaures en
fait il était vivipare ou ovipare c'est
à dire que là si ça c'est un oeuf de
mozart ça veut dire que les mosasaures
était vivipare ou ovovivipare était
ovipare ou ovovivipare alors sachant que
vous viviez par d'après ce que j'ai
compris on le dit plus vraiment mais
bref ils prendraient un oeuf et 7,9 vite
fait et que éclairerait juste après
avoir été pondus donc ce serait de l'eau
vauvy parité on peut pas plus
ovovivipare en même temps je veux dire
il prend 1,9 et l'oeuf est clos tout de
suite après donc c'est vivipare mais
juste après avoir été ovipare donc si on
n'utilise pas vous viviez part pour ça
je sais pas pourquoi on utilise mais
bref je m'égare là voilà c'est donc ça
ce serait la preuve en gros que les
mozart pondait encore des oeufs et ne
donnait pas de naissance comme les
plésiosaures et les ichthyosaures un
bébé qui était déjà vivant et donc ça ça
a l'air de proposer problème à pas mal
de monde parce que bah ça veut dire que
comment est ce que l'on entre le moment
où lambris enfin entre le bébé sort du
ventre et où il sort de son oeuf en gros
l'embryon il est en roue libre et il
peut pas respirer
bon on a tout ce qu'on a là c'est la
coquille ça veut pas dire qu'il y avait
pas une chambre à air à l'intérieur
peut-être qu'il y avait une chambre à
air je sais pas peut-être qu'il y avait
une petite réserve peut-être que les
mozart ont une certaine tolérance les
mozart bébés ont une certaine tolérance
à la knoxy je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas si c'est du mozart bassée
c'est embêtant parce que ça voudrait
dire que c'était possiblement un c'était
possiblement ça aurait pu être un
problème par rapport à son adaptation au
milieu aquatique tout simplement dont il
ya des gens qui ont fait l'hypothèse que
ça pourrait être un de ces fameux
dinosaures à nous comme un artiste yahoo
1 à belize au rider donc un
ornithischiens parce que les
ornithischiens devrait avoir les homes
ou primitivement ou un à belize au rider
parce que les abbés leader idée devrait
devrait se trouver là à la base des
théropodes et que peut-être il avait les
mots c'est pas du c'est pas bien mais
peut-être qu'ils avaient les yeux me pas
sauropodes parce que les sauropodes en
un an dans cette région là en
antarctique sont deux auraient plutôt
tendance à être des titanosaures on est
sur le gondwana donc les sauropodes du
gondwana ce sont les titanosaures l'été
donc bon voilà voilà où on en est on
sait pas trop on sait pas trop bon peu
après ils ont exclu aussi le dinosaure
parce que quand on regarde ce qu'ils
trouvent dans cette formation qui
s'appelle la formation lopez d'artaud
dano ya pas de ya pas de dinosaures un
en face il ya 2 il ya deux l'ornitho
potes mais les ornithologues dillon a
qui sont à coki dur et il y a et c'est
tout voilà donc
donc c'est tout ce qu'ils ont après ils
ont du requin je crois mais bon les
requins ils n'ont pas vraiment de ils
sont disqualifiés
ils ont dû plaire aux ormes et les
ptérosaures ils sont trop petits pour
pouvoir avoir pondu un oeuf de la taille
d'un ballon de rugby donc les seuls
candidats possibles c'est le sait le
plésiosaure et le mozart donc si c'est
du plaisir aux orres bas c'est un
problème parce que on a des preuves que
les plésiosaures son vivipare et si
c'est du mozart bas ça pose problème
mais moins que plésiosaures voilà parce
que pour l'instant les mosasaures on a
pas vraiment de preuve qu'ils étaient
vivier pas tout ce qu'on a
en preuve de vie parité chez les
mosasaures c'est cet article là du moins
c'est le seul que je connais et ce
qu'ils ont trouvé ces des embryons à
l'intérieur d'un
d'une maman me azor et mais bon ces
embryons ils sont pas du tout prêts à
sortir ces embryons ils sont organisés
voilà il sait chacun chacun a sa petite
boule en fait ils sont ils sont
reconstitués tel quel chacun a sa petite
boule il ya 1 2 3 4 5 et donc ils sont
chacun dans leurs petites bulles comme
reconstituer ici et on peut imaginer ce
qu'on veut au tour c'est à dire qu'on
peut imaginer un oeuf tel que celui là
autour tout à fait là là il imagina
place à tapas que eux ils veulent partir
sur la vie parité mais sachant que là
ils sont pas la tête parce que là la
tête elle est orientée par la la la tête
elle est orientée par la la la tête
alors orienté par la la la tête elle est
orientée par là il y en a aucun qui a la
tête qui est orienté vers le canal le
canal de naissance quoi le canal pelvien
donc il y en a aucun qui est sur le
point de sortir s'il avait encore la
tête tournée vers le canal pelvien on
pourrait dire qu'ils sortaient la tête
la première pour aller respirer tout de
suite mais c'est pas le cas donc là il y
en a aucun qui est sur le point de
naître et on peut tout à fait imaginer
qu'ils étaient entourés d'une d'une
membrane qui n'a pas été préservés
exactement comme ce qu'ils font là mais
que pour une raison que j'ignore ils
préfèrent privilégier la vie parité bah
c'est pas une raison que j'ignore c'est
parce que parce qu'on s'imagine
difficilement un oeuf sortir puis enfin
comme j'ai dit le bébé serait en roue
libre entre le moment où il est pendu et
et le moment il doit aller respirer mais
bon et normalement avec une membrane
aussi fine les échanges gazeux avec une
membrane aussi fine que cette oeuvre
dans dark tollitte us dans tactical hit
us les échanges gazeux devait se faire à
travers la membrane donc à partir du
moment où le fait pondu ya plus
d'échangés gazeux possible mais bon
peut-être il y avait une poche d'air
peut-être le bébé sortait effectivement
instantanément après que l'oeuf et été
pondus on sait pas mais en tout cas le
mozart c'est le moins problématique
voilà donc faut bien admettre que cette
identification à partir d'un mot zaz or
c'est la moins problématique après on
peut imaginer que ça vient d'un
dinosaure mais si ça vient d'un
dinosaure ben ça s'est retrouvé dans le
milieu marin d'une façon ou d'une autre
et
et il n'y a pas de dinosaures qui
correspondent dans la formation en
question surtout voilà donc il n'y a pas
deux il n'ya pas les dinosaures qu'il
faut là où il faut
on va dire pour faire un bon candidat
donc affaire à suivre
j'ai envie de dire pour l'instant le
mozart c'est la meilleure hypothèse
qu'on a c'est pas c'est pas les potez
parfaite c'est clair elle est ouverte à
contestation tout le monde le conçoit
mais ça reste la meilleure jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
et évidemment on va terminer par le
spinosaures spinosaurus mon amour qui
fait toujours et encore parler de lui
alors bon c'est un article qui est sorti
qui est sorti presque en même temps que
le nouvel article sur le spinosaures sur
la queue de spinosaures il ya trois
articles qui sont sortis en rafale on en
a couvert 2 avec mon collègue christophe
hendrix donc je vous invite à aller voir
la vidéo on a couvert déjà deux de ses
articles on en a parlé en détail mais
maintenant j'aimerais revenir sur ce
troisième article qui est sorti un peu
après la vidéo est qui et qui est
intéressant parce que parce que parce
que parce que il prend tous les
spinosaures et enfin il prend tous les
spinosaures idées et d'afrique du nord
et il en fait tous spinosaurus égyptiens
cus et évidemment ça fait râler beaucoup
de monde j'ai moi le premier a
d'ailleurs j'ai fait ce même là qui dit
en gros
toi tu es à spinosaures toi tu es un
spinosaures tout le monde il ya un
spinosaures voilà et tout le monde
maintenant il est un spin aux régies et
un spinosaurus égyptiens accusent la
question donc évidemment ça a soulevé
beaucoup de débats sur est ce qu'on peut
vraiment se permettre de synonymes ise
des trucs à ce point là et qu'est ce que
ça apporte finalement de synonymes ise
des trucs à ce poids là bon il ya des
choses qui ont été mises en synonymie
dans cet article avec spinosaures riche
et égyptiens cus c'est plutôt
raisonnable genre
genre le spinosaurus b qui est qui est
une morphologie qui a qui est un
fragment de spinosaures avec une
morphologie légèrement différente du
spinosaurus original bon il n'y a pas
vraiment de raison de maintenir sa
différent de spinosaurus égyptiens cus
spinosaurus maroccan us qui était pas
non plus hyper différent et il ya les
deux qui ont vraiment fait gueuler si
gilles massa zaurus et hawks à leiria
donc si gilles massa au russe c'est
parce que c'est une vertèbre et que sept
vertèbres elle est très elle semble très
différente pour les spécialistes de
spinosaurus égyptiens cus et hawks à la
ja qui fait que les les spécialistes et
les non spécialistes parce que lui il se
trouve au brésil
donc on est un peu loin de la patrie du
spinosaurus égyptiens cus qui comme son
nom l'indiqué se trouve plutôt en
afrique du nord
donc quoi penser de ces synonymie quoi
penser de ces synonymie comme j'ai dit
après je suis pas spécialiste de
spinosaurus 1 ni même des vertèbres de
de dinosaures donc spinosaurus b
spinosaurus maroccan us c'est des
morceaux qui sont trouvés dans la dans
l'air de répartition de spinosaurus
égyptiens cus et qui ressemble
suffisamment à spinosaurus égyptiens
accusent du mois ce que j'ai lu de
l'article j'ai trouvé que ouais il
soulignait bien les ressemblances donc
il ya pas tellement de de gros problèmes
à synonyme ise ça avec spinosaurus
égyptiens cus avec une marge raisonnable
de variabilité si gilles massa zaurus il
semblerait qu'il soit très très très
différents donc après voilà spinosaurus
c'est quand même une espèce enfin
spineux oui spinosaurus c'est quand même
un genre pardon égyptiens cus c'est une
espèce qui est caractérisé par sa voix
par son voile dorsale sa voile dorsale
et 7
je veux dire cette voile dorsale on peut
raisonnablement supposer qu'elle devait
être différente entre les sexes etc en
fonction de si vous aviez une voile
dorsale ou non vous pouvez avoir des
vertèbres très différentes
alla donc si on part sur le principe
d'un dimorphisme sexuel on peut quand
même s'attendre à ce que les vertèbres
du dos soit différente entre mâles et
femelles et donc il paraît totalement
exclue voilà qui est 2 morphologie
différente de spinosaurus égyptiens cus
c'est pas exactement leur ligne de
défense dans cet article mais disons que
voilà comme je les dis n'étant pas
spécialiste je veux bien croire que la
variabilité d'une espèce peut recouvrir
à ce point des différences
morphologiques comme ça maintenant voilà
seul le futur nous le dira je veux dire
si gilles massa au russe sait que des
vertèbres
c'est que des vertèbres je voulais
montre la voie là c'est que des
vertèbres donc qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
juste des vertèbres le en fait le
conflit entre si gilles massa aux russes
et spinosaurus égyptiens accusent ce
n'est pas tellement un conflit entre
entre ces deux espèces là c'est pas
tellement un conflit de fautes il
l'appeler si gilles massa au russo
spinosaurus c'est un conflit entre des
gens qu'on appelle les limpers et des
gens qu'on appelle les spleeters les
lums peur c'est les gens qui veut qui
voit plein de restes de dinosaures
différents mais qui disent ouais mais
non mais c'est tout la même espèce et de
la variabilité allez hop c'est de la
variabilité intraspécifique il avait
peut-être pas le même âge ils avaient
peut-être pas le même sexe ou peut-être
que l'espèce était hyper variable je
veux dire aujourd'hui vous regardez la
dentition des cochons domestiques
enfin je veux dire vous pouvez trouver
des cochons avec des antilles fit avec
des dentitions totalement différentes et
pourtant si vous avez suivi ma
mais épisodes sur la femme et court sur
la sur l'évolution des mammifères
vous savez que la dentition c'est le
caractère sacré des mammifères c'est le
truc est censé vous révéler absolument
tout sur les mammifères y compris leur
taxonomie est là je suis en train de
vous dire qu'en gros les cochons c'est
du n'importe quoi et voilà si ici on
sait si on se contentait de la dentition
il y aurait trois mille espèces de
cochon quoi domestique et pareil pour
l'être humain d'ailleurs si on se
contentait de la dentition clairement
les aborigènes d'australie
les bushmen d'afrique du sud et les
européens feraient pas partie de la même
espèce
si on se contentait de la dentition mais
c'est pas le cas heureusement et puis on
a accès à la génétique et tout ça donc
voilà si si on se contentait que de la
dentition il ya des fois où on serait
quand même bien paumé et donc là le chez
les dinosaures
le truc que les gens utilisent le plus
c'est généralement les vertèbres ou le
bassin et du crâne quand ils ont du
crâne donc hélas les vertèbres elles ont
l'air de dire deux espèces oui mais on
n'est pas à l'abri qui est une espèce
avec une variabilité morphologiques
diront que c'est une grosse hypothèse à
faire quand même cette variabilité au
morphologiques mais ce n'est pas
impossible et donc les loopers qui sont
les gens qui aiment réunir les espèces
bah c'est ce que fait c'est ce que font
ses auteurs la dont ils n'y arrivent
brahim fait parti nizar ibrahim celui
qui a décrit le nouveau spinosaure de
donc voila se lasser des lovers ils
veulent que tout ça se soit spinosaurus
égyptiens cus et basta et puis vous avez
les spleeters comme sergio chat et vert
ce qui a ravi qui a ravivé sijilmassa
zaurus en 2015 je crois ou en 2016 je ne
sais plus mais bref c'est lui qui a
ressuscité un peu sijilmassa zaurus or
désormais dans les vertèbres sont trop
différentes puisque ça avait déjà été
mis en synonymie je crois avec
spinosaurus mais bref c'est tout ça
c'est des histoires deux taxonomistes
c'est juste pour dire que voilà il ya
les spleeters qui aime bien séparés il
ya les l'homme parce qu'ils aiment
rassembler et je pense que c'est plus
une
un conflit entre ces deux là c'est à
dire que les spleeters mbia lisa ils ont
ils izem le souci du détail et quand il
voit un petit détail qui est différent
il aime bien créer une nouvelle espèce
ça c'est une philosophie de spleeters et
les loopers ils disent mais regardez la
variabilité des espèces modernes vos
petits détails valeur
a rassemblé moi tout ça et rendez sa
plus simple voilà il ya donc d'un côté
il ya une volonté de s'accrocher aux
petits détails et de l'autre côté il ya
une volonté de simplifier les choses
aussi c'est un débat qui est éternel et
qui le sont et qui le restera donc voilà
si gilles massa zaurus bref je ne me
prononce pas il ya que quand on
découvrira des restes plus complet d'un
truc qui aura la même morphologie
vertébrale que si gilles massa zaurus
qu'on pourra dire voilà si c'est si le
reste du squelette est significativement
différents de spinosaurus ou pas et si
c'est dû dimorphisme sexuel ça peut
prendre mais alors très très très très
longtemps
l'art très très très très très longtemps
parce que ouais le dimorphisme sexuel
c'est très très dur a démontré avec le
registre fossile donc voilà c'est chez
les dinosaures à la limite on peut
regarder si on trouve des eaux l'on peut
regarder les oslon faire des coupes à
l'intérieur et voir s'il ya du tissu
s'il ya ce tissu à l'intérieur des eaux
qui sert à faire les coquilles d'oeuf
qui sert de réservoir pour faire les
coquilles d'oeuf
mais le problème c'est que même les
femelles n'ont pas ça tout le temps donc
seulement quand elles pondent leurs
oeufs
donc on peut tourner en rond très
longtemps avec ce débat voilà mais
vouloir dire que il ya que spinosaurus
où il n'y a pas que spinosaurus quand on
n'est pas spécialiste c'est un peu
chaude c'est un peu chaud de la zizou et
puis il ya hawks ali à qui l'on mène 6
donc qui nous vient du brésil est alors
celui là par contre c'est un cas
particulier parce que parce que parce
que je veux vous montrer
ouais j'ai oublié de parler du coût des
carrés l'écart est donc c'est ce
qu'avait montré christophe hendrix est
d'ailleurs la dernière fois qu'on a
discuté ensemble sur la chaîne il a
oublié lui aussi d'en parler l'écart est
donc c'est l'os qui articule le crâne à
la mâchoire et christophe hendrix les a
étudiées et il a trouvé qu'il y avait
deux morphologie dans les carrés de
spinosaures idée d'afrique du nord ce
qui soutiendrait qu'il y avait deux
espèces donc spinosaurus égyptiens cus
et si gilles massa zaurus au moins et
alors ça ça a été utilisé aussi comme un
argument fort comme quoi il ya comme
quoi si gilles massa au russe est valide
le truc c'est que objectivement on peut
dire que c'est carré appartiennent à
sigi le massage aux russes par
élimination on peut dire que c'est carré
appartiennent à ce sujet le massage aux
russes mais on peut pas dire
objectivement qu'ils lisent ils lui
appartiennent
peut-être que c'est une troisième espèce
donc ça c'est carré ne peuvent pas être
identifiés comme si gilles massa au
russe et il ya un truc qu'il faut bien
un prix mais quand on fait quand on a
affaire à ce genre de débat c'est aussi
que le fait de dire que spinosaurus
égyptiens cus est la seule espèce valide
en afrique du nord ne fait pas de
spinosaurus égyptiens cus la seule
espèce en afrique du nord
c'est la seule espèce valide sa ve ca
veux pouvoir dire qu'il y à d'autres
restent parcellaires
comme l'écart est comme des vertèbres
dont la morphologie ne colle pas avec
spinosaurus égyptiens accusent mais qui
pourrait représenter une espèce
différente c'est juste qu'il ya pas
assez de matériel et qu'on devrait se
limiter au matériel qui est relativement
complet donc le matériel de spinosaurus
qui est maintenant beaucoup mieux
représentés qu'il ne l'était avant
donc c'est ça aussi la petite subtilité
qu'il faut comprendre c'est dire que
spinosaurus égyptiens qc la seule espèce
valide ça veut pas dire qu'il ya que
spinosaurus égyptiens cus ça veut dire
que c'est la seule qui est représenté
par des restes diagnostic et dans
l'article dans cet article la ce qu'ils
disent en gros c'est les restes
diagnostic c'est nous qui les avons
c'est spinosaurus égyptiens cus c'est
notre squelette à nous qu'on a déterré
qu'on a présenté en 2014
c'est le néo type et le reste les
vertèbres isolé de machin l'écart est
isolée de bidules s'est pas dit c'est
pas diagnostic donc jusqu'à preuve du
contraire c'est spinosaurus égyptiens
accusent c'est ça qu'ils disent mais il
faut bien faut pas perdre de vue que ça
veut pas dire qu'ils négligent ou qu'ils
mettent de côté cette variabilité ça
veut juste dire bon bah il ya de la
variabilité pour l'instant
le truc c'est que c'est trop c'est trop
parcellaires et c'est ça ou c'est là où
je veux en venir entre les l'homme peut
recéler spleeters c'est que les limpers
ils vont avoir tendance à regarder ça en
se disant bas c'est bien joli mais c'est
pas assez pour faire une nouvelle espèce
justin carey des vertèbres et une
vertèbre isolé je veux dire c'est pas
assez pour ériger une nouvelle espèce si
on se met à ériger une nouvelle espèce
pour chaque petit détail qu'on voit sur
une vertèbre on en est pas sorti et les
sprinteurs ils vont dire bah oui mais
vous négligez cette variabilité non la
néglige pas on la met de côté diront les
limpers donc voilà c'est là où je veux
en venir c'est il faut vraiment pas
perdre de vue que ces deux philosophies
en fait mais que c'est pas parce qu'on
dit que spinosaurus égyptiens qc la
seule espèce valides qui a pas d'autres
espèces ça par contre faut bien être
d'accord là dessus voilà mais maintenant
dont koksal ya le spinosaurus d'afrique
d'amérique du sud pardon du brésil
donc là ce qu'ils font dans ce
paragraphe c il parle de hawx alia
de hawx alia il leur décrivent et ils en
font en fait
ils prennent tous les caractères qui
font qui ferait de koksal ya un spécimen
unique
alors il s'agirait d'un morceau de
maxillaire et d'un petit bout de crâne
voilà il n'ya pas grand-chose de cox
alias et très parcellaire encore une
fois donc le maxillaire c'est l'os qui
porte les dents mais les demandes elles
mêmes sont pas spécialement bien
préservés donc ya pas grand chose à se
mettre sous la dent là typiquement
spleeters un fait une nouvelle espèce et
les loopers se passe derrière en disant
mais vous faites pour une nouvelle
espèce avec un truc comme ça quoi c'est
trop il n'y a pas assez pour faire une
nouvelle espèce c'est tout pourri c'est
mal préservé bref voilà donc encore une
fois il ya un split heures qui a fait
une nouvelle espèce il ya un homme peur
qui passe derrière pour dire que c'est
la même espèce qu'autre chose et il y
aura probablement un autre spliter pour
repasser derrière pour redire que c'est
différent mais bref et donc ils refont
ils reprennent les caractères un parent
en disant que ces caractères ne sont pas
différents d'autres spinosaures donc au
ctia lien est pareil que spinosaurus
c'est pareil que sue chemim us pour ça
ce caractère hawks alia et pareil que
hérite à tort pour tel autre caractère
et donc la conclusion c'est la
conclusion elle est ici que je vais vous
traduire dès maintenant puisque après on
passe à un autre paragraphe
donc c'est la seule haute à pommard
filles restantes dont côte apomorphine
c'est un caractère typique à cette
espèce en particulier donc la seule
haute apomorphine restante est là la
texture sculpté du prêt maxillaire si
cela était la seule au tableau morphy
proposé entre ce matériel et du matériel
plus complet alors ce ne serait
certainement pas suffisant pour en faire
une nouvelle espèce et encore moins un
genre différent parce qu'évidemment
c'est cox alias et pas seulement une
espèce différente de spinosaurus c'est
aussi un autre genre que spinosaurus ses
eaux sales ya donc
donc là on a plus en gros il ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est qu'ils ont d'élite et
toutes les hautes apomorphine tous les
caractères typiques de cette espèce
jusqu'au point où il n'en reste plus
qu'une qui est la texture sculpté du
prêt maxillaire
et tout seul pour eux étant donné qu'ils
sont des limpers pour eux juste une ôta
pour murphy ça ne suffit pas alors qu'un
spleeters pour lui ça suffirait et donc
ils disent c'est pas suffisant pour en
faire son propre genre sur cette base
nous disons que hawx alia qui l'emmène 6
est un synonyme junior de spinosaurus
égyptiens cus en attendant de nouvelles
découvertes d'un matériel plus
d'agnostiques donc en gros ils disent
dans cette phrase hawks alias ça marche
pas il n'y a pas assez de caractère on
en fait spinosaurus égyptiens cus et
c'est là que je suis pas d'accord c'est
là que je suis pas du tout mais alors
pas du tout du tout d'accord et que
personne à mon avis ne peux être
d'accord avec leurs conclusions ici et
je sais pas du tout comment ça s'est
passé à travers le peer review bing ceci
étant dit vous voyez que l'article est
pas mise en page
ce qui veut dire que c'est un prêt
prouve ce qui veut dire que les
modifications peuvent arriver entre deux
ça m'étonnerait que ça arrive mais bon
pourquoi pas normalement la seule
modification entre une pré proof et la
publication c'est la mise en page
mais bon qui sait peut-être que
quelqu'un va gueuler suffisamment formé
en tout cas oui là là il ya un problème
là il ya un problème parce que les hôtes
apomorphine sont pas suffisants pour en
faire une nouvelle espèce
on est d'accord enfin on est d'accord on
peut débattre mais moi je vais pas
débattre parce que je suis pas
spécialiste
donc on va partir du principe qu on est
d'accord il n'y a pas suffisamment d'eau
tapo murphy pour dire que c'est une
espèce à part entière très bien la
conclusion de ça ça devrait être hawks
alias ça n'existe pas et on en fait un
homme n du biome donc un nom douteux
hawks alias était un nom douteux basés
sur le matériel douteux c'est ce qu'on
devrait faire normalement c'est ce que
dit le code de nomenclature n'ont eux
ils disent hawks alia il n'y a pas de
dota pour murphy donc c'est spinosaurus
pardon pardon vous pouvez répéter ça
s'il vous plaît c'est donc ya pas il n'y
a pas de caractère donc c'est
spinosaurus na c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche pour pouvoir dire que c'est
spinosaurus il faudrait pouvoir dire au
xaia n'a aucun caractère particulier à
lui par contre il a t'elle tel tel et
tel caractère qui sont présents chez
spinosaurus et uniquement chez
spinosaurus
et ça dans toute la liste de trucs
qu'ils ont présentés au dessus y'a pas
le dire il ya dès qu'il ya des
caractères comme il dit qui sont
présents chez angaturama irrite à tort
il ya des caractères qui sont présents
chez su comme hymus enfin bref c'est un
joyeux bordel
il n'y a pas de caractère qui soit
unique à spinosaurus 1 là il ya même là
ils disent n'y a pas de différences
entre oksa lia et spinosaurus mais enfin
c'est pas parce qu'il ya pas de
différence qu'ils sont pareils c'est
parce qu a pas de différences visibles
sur le matériel qu'on a qui sont à bout
de maxillaire à bout de crâne pourri
donc faut pas non plus pousser mémé dans
les orties
sur ce coup là là il ya clairement abus
et il ya d'autant plus un but quand on
est sur deux continents différents quand
même un ya d'autant plus abus cox alias
et au brésil donc bon je sais que
maintenant
à force de publier dans nature's que
spinosaurus est aquatique
on va finir par convaincre les gens
qu'ils l'étaient vraiment mais même ça
c'est encore débattues on va y revenir
un petit peu après voilà je sais qu'à
force de marteler dans l'esprit des gens
que spinosaurus et semi aquatiques ont
fini par faire passer l'idée qu'il
pouvait avoir traversé l'atlantique au
crétacé comme une idée raisonnable mais
mais là c'est pas une preuve ça c'est
pas une preuve
donc là ça sent un petit peu comme il
s'agit comme je le disais de la même
équipe que les gens qui ont publié
spinosaurus est aquatique
on sent un petit peu une volonté de
vouloir enfoncer le clou 2
de la biologie aquatique de spinosaurus
un petit peu artificiellement du monde
en disant vous voyez il ya du
spinosaurus au brésil ça voulait dire
qu'il savait nager
ouais non là c'est un peu circulaire
comme raisonnement là se fait pas beau
c'est sale c'est sale ce qui est en
train de se produire et donc non non
enfin raisonnablement on peut pas dire
cox alias et spinosaurus au mieux hawks
à lire est un domaine du bio ce qui est
dommage pour les brésiliens qui viennent
de perdre une espèces de spinosaures
idée mais en tout cas ça fait pas de
spinosaures ça le fait pas d'auxiliaire
un spinosaurus égyptiens cus
d'autant que c'est pas une petite
hypothèse je veux dire c'est pas comme
quand on dit si gilles massa zaurus
c'est un spinosaurus égyptiens accusent
quand on dit si j'ai le massage aussi un
spinosaurus égyptiens cus
on reste dans l'air de répartition de
spinosaurus ont fait pas de grosses
hypothèse paléogéographiques là il faut
quand même admettre que spinosaurus a
traversé un continent avec tous enfin à
traverser un océan sur 1 et pour arriver
sur un autre continent
avec tout ce que ça implique donc c'est
pas une petite hypothèse là c'est une
hypothèse massive là on aimerait bien
qu'il ya un peu plus que bon ben c'est
pas c'est pas une vraie espèces alors
c'est spinosaurus non non non déjà déjà
déjà seahawks alia avait été trouvé en
afrique du nord ça suffirait pas à dire
que c'est spinosaurus met alors en plus
sachant qu'ils aient trouvé au brésil
c'est chaud non c'est chaud alors oui ça
pourrait ça pourrait mais il n'y a pas
de bonnes raisons de le croire
voilà c'est ça le truc un nom mais je
vous vois j'imagine déjà en train de
débattre dans les commentaires de ben
oui mais ça pourrait quand même être
spinosaurus vu qu'ils savaient nager oui
mais non oui mais non c'est ça pourrait
mais c'est pas une bonne raison de le
croire
ce sera une bonne raison de le croire
quand vous trouverez une des restes
diagnostic de spinosaurus avec des
caractères qu'on ne retrouve que chez
spinosaurus égyptiens accusent et chez
personne d'autre
là oui mais c'est pas le cas d'autres
salles ya en tout cas pas d'après cet
article puisque encore une fois je ne me
base que sur l'article je ne connais pas
les spinosaures hills les spinosaures
idée plus que ça autrement quoi mais
d'après ce que ce qui est dit dans cet
article ça ne suffit pas à faire donc
s'allier à autre chose que canaux mène
du biome quoi et donc est donc chose
promise chose dûe on va parler justement
de cette reconstitution de 2014 parce
qu'il ya effectivement beaucoup beaucoup
de contestations donc ce qui va il va
falloir déjà faire un point parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de monde qui gueule sur
cette reconstruction de spinosaurus en
disant que les jambes sont trop courtes
que les bras sont trop gros que qu'on
n'a pas assez de matériel des bras pour
dire que les bras était proportionnée
comme ça par rapport aux jambes etc
les critiques sont valides
les critiques sont valides mais encore
une fois on va nuancé il va falloir
nuance est donc déjà on va mettre au
point la différence entre le néo type et
la reconstitution de 2014
parce que ça c'est un truc que les gens
ont tendance à mixer ensemble et ça
pourrit un peu les débats sur la
validité justement de la reconstitution
de 2014 et du caractère semi aquatique
de spinosaurus c'est quoi le néo type
c'est quoi la différence avec la
reconstitution de 2014 donc le néo types
tels que présentés en 2014 c'était ça
une jambe des vertèbres et des bouts de
verre table de que des bouts de verre
table dorsale des bouts de vertèbres de
cul voilà et un bassin donc ça c'est le
néo type et il ya des morceaux il ya des
petits fragments associé de crâne de
phalanges d'autres bouts de werther ou
etc
c'est mais sinon voilà le néo type c'est
surtout la guibole quoi et c'est ce qui
est représenté en rouge ici donc vous
voyez d'ailleurs les vertèbres j'ai pas
l'impression qu'elle soit située au bon
endroit
ici mais bref en tout cas sont pas
situés au même endroit sur la
reconstitution de 2020 que sur cette
photo qui a été fait en 2014 imagine
qu'ils ont un peu condenser le boom
ils ont dû un peu condenser le bouzin
pour la photo 1
c'est pas non plus je veux dire c'est ça
va cesser les guides quoi mais bref ça
représente quand même les proportions du
bestiau quoi c'est ce qu'on a donné au
type c'est ça donc il ya des bonnes
vertèbres on va dire et il ya une patte
arrière est ce que nous avait dit donc
christophe hendrix à propos de ça c'est
que effectivement la patte arrière est
relativement petit par rapport aux
tailles à la taille des vertèbres ça il
n'ya pas apparemment d'après lui il n'y
a pas trop à tortiller du cul
les vertèbres sont quand même balèze par
rapport aux guiboles et après il ya une
phalange c'est pas exactement c'est pas
exactement la panacée pour enfin une
phalange des masses est pas exactement
la panacée pour discuter de la
proportion des bras donc ça c'est le néo
type m
et le néo type en 2020 s'est vu
additionnez la queue qui a été retrouvé
au même endroit l'accueil était
complètement articulé elle était
quasiment en continuité avec ce qu'il
endroit où elle avait été trouvée le
bassin il n'y a pas grande raison de
douter que la queue ne va pas avec ce
n'est au type donc c'est ça semblerait
être là que dîner au type est encore une
fois vous regardez là que lé super
longue comparée à la la petitesse des
membres enfin des jambes donc les jambes
elle le fait que les jambes son petit ça
a l'air les gîtes ça ça a l'air quand
même de fonctionner quoi
bon mais par contre c'est la proportion
avec les bras qui fait débat et la
proportion avec les bras elle elle vient
pas du néo type
elle vient de ça elle vient de la
reconstitution de 2014 donc j'ai repris
directement la slide de quand on en
avait parlé avec christophe il ya en
2014 à l'époque où le papier était sorti
donc pareil si vous voulez aller voir la
vidéo c'est par là elle est un peu
vieille leçon est un peu moisie mais bon
au moins on en parle et est donc là là
par contre on a effectivement en rouge
le néo type et après on a en plein de
couleurs différentes d'autres fragments
qui ont été rajoutées à ça je crois que
les seuls fragments
je crois que c'est envers les fragments
qui qui manquent réellement à moins que
ce soit en bleu je ne sais pas si ça
doit être en bleu les fragments qui
manquent réellement en tout cas en jaune
c'est des morceaux qui est con à orange
je sais que c'est des morceaux qu'on a
ce serait bizarre de mettre envers des
morceaux qu'on n'a pas donc je pense que
c'est ce qu'ils sont en bleu qu'on a pas
puisque il s'agit essentiellement de la
queue et que la queue du coup on l'a
retrouvé plus tard donc je pense que
c'est en bleu c'est soit les morceaux en
bleu sur les morceaux en verre qui
manquent mais bref
donc ça c'est un composite la grosse
idée de toute façon que quelles que
soient les morceaux manquants la grosse
idée c'est que ça c'est un composite
c'est à dire que chaque couleur
correspond à quelque chose qui vient
d'ailleurs que lolo type soit qui a été
reconstituée avec de la spéculation
rationnelle soit qui a été reconstituée
avec des morceaux de d'un autre animal
qui vient d'un autre spinosaurus
égyptiens accusent du moins d'un autre
morceau attribué à spinosaurus égyptiens
accusent donc il ya les morceaux qui
viennent de du premier spécimen en
orange c'est le premier spécimen qui a
été trouvé par straumur enfin décrit par
turner dans les années dans les années
30 qui a été démolie mais bon il est il
est reconstituée à bhl à partir des
photos
et puis vous avez d'autres morceaux vous
avez le
le museau qui avait été décrit par dal
sasso par exemple enfin bref c'est des
morceaux qui viennent d'ailleurs et donc
là ce qui a fait que les à l'époque
c'est qu'effectivement quand on regarde
les proportions de la jambe par rapport
aux bras le premier truc qu'on se dit
c'est ouais ça c'est des jambes de
juvéniles et ça c'est des bras d'adulte
en gros et vous avez connaissant
ensemble en disant que c'était la même
bestioles et basta maintenant vous dites
qu'il est semi aquatique
bon maintenant qu'on a la queue et qu'on
sait que la queue était super longue et
maintenant et je veux dire que les
vertes elles sont super gros c'est tout
bon lit est possible que en fait ces
proportions soient plus ou moins
réalistes après il ya eu des discussions
parmi les les paléo artistes qui disait
que sur cette image là en particulier
les jambes étaient vraiment trop petit
comparé à ce qu'elles le sont réellement
c'est à dire que la reconstitution d'un
point de vue simplement pictural était
était pas tout à fait était pas précise
sur cette image là quoi voilà mais sinon
les jambes sont quand même relativement
petit par rapport au reste de l'animal
donc c'est toujours débat table voilà le
le caractère aquatique il ya aussi le
côté ou voilà juste foot un morceau de
peau lit de poly de pvc dans la flotte
et le faire se secouer c'est comme le
comme je le disais dans l'interview de
christophe on voit bien la science
fassions national geographic on voit
bien on voit moins la science tout court
[Rires]
c'est à dire c'est une science à
spectacle mais bon ça fait c'est joli
mais voilà qu'est ce que ça démontre on
sait pas trop quoi
bon bref le jeu trouve ce qui ce qui
soutient le mieux le fait que
spinosaurus est aquatique c'est que sur
ses vertèbres caudales qu'ils ont trouvé
en 2020 elles sont tout articulé est
normalement elle devrait être bien
compact et bien serrées les unes sur les
autres comme c'est le cas chez la
plupart des autres théropodes lassé par
le cas l'attitude l'articulation entre
les vertèbres et super légères donc ça
dénote d'une certaine mobilité quoi donc
ça mon avis c'est l'argument le plus
convaincant de du fait que cette queue
était utilisé pour nager l'argument le
plus convaincant que spinosaurus il est
semi aquatique ça vient des analyses
isotopiques et ça vient d
ça vient des coupes qui ont été faits
dans les eaux de spinosaurus qui montre
que c'est que ces eaux était très dense
et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve
chez les espèces modernes semi-aquatique
chez qui les eau sont utilisés comme des
ballasts pour tenir l'animal dans l'eau
malgré le fait que sa flottabilité
normalement devrait le maintenir à la
surface les animaux en moyenne
contiennent un peu trop de gras et d'air
dans leurs poumons pour ne pas flotter
donc globalement globalement ça voudrait
dire que spinosaurus avait des eaux plus
dense pour pouvoir tenir au fond et ça
c'est une adaptation à un mode de vie
semi-aquatique donc voilà les arguments
pour un mode de vie semi-aquatique ils
sont là
la proportion des bras par rapport aux
jambes j'ai envie de dire c'est plus une
question de paléo artistes qu'autre
chose
après il ya aussi la question de s qui
marchait sur ses phalanges de devant où
pas comme c'est le cas sur certaines
représentations mais encore une fois
c'est une
c'est une question de paléo artiste ça
c'est pas tellement une question de
science puisqu'on n'a pas toutes façons
de comme vous voyez là on n'a pas de
beaux bras de spinosaurus on a on a des
morceaux on a des morceaux par ci par là
et la mécanique des bras pour pouvoir
l'étudier il faut avoir des bras en
entier donc là bon on a quand même des
choses pas trop mal je l'iran là on a
quand même un numerus un radius bonbons
est-ce qu'on peut à ce qu'on peut faire
vraiment de la biomécanique avec ça
normalement on devrait voir des
adaptations sur les phalanges si marché
vraiment sur les phalanges ce qui n'a
pas vraiment l'air d'être le cas a
priori les gens qui ont regardé ça n'ont
pas l'air de voir des adaptations sur
les phalanges qui montrait qu'il
marchait sur ses pattes de devant ah oui
et puis un autre bah oui il ya un autre
truc qui est très discutée c est ce qu
il avait une palme mur aussi au pied il
semblerait qu'il n'y a pas de griffe au
pied et que les doigts soit très écartés
donc ça voudrait dire que en gros il y
avait des palmes et que ses pieds
n'avait pas de grosses griffes de coups
ça veut dire ses pieds étaient pas
tellement utilisée pour chasser ce qui
va de pair avec le fait que les jambes
étaient plutôt faiblarde
donc ça c'est bon c'est
c'est une hypothèse c'est une hypothèse
c'est du tissu mou donc ça veut dire
qu'on aura probablement jamais la preuve
voilà fin du défunt du débat a pas à pas
retrouvé un spinosaurus magnifiquement
préservé avec les tissus mous qui
montrent qu'ils avaient une pâle mur je
veux dire ou des empreintes de
spinosaurus et encore on aurait des
empreintes palme est de taille
compatible avec spinosaurus
éventuellement oui là ce qui pourrait
démontrer démontré qu il marcher ou non
sur ses sur ses phalanges ce serait des
empreintes de mains voila faudrait
trouver faudrait trouver des empreintes
qu'on pourrait attribuer à spinosaurus
donc peut-être justement de taille
comparable à spinosaurus avec une palme
sûrs et ce que ses empreintes soient
quadrupède
voilà mais bon ça c'est à dire que là
pour l'instant le registre fossile des
empreintes du crétacé de là où on a
trouvé les spinosaures je crois pas
qu'on en est tant que ça je
je connais pas beaucoup d'empreintes de
d'empreintes de dinosaures d'afrique du
nord si vous en connaissez des sites en
emprunte d'afrique du nord et qui datent
de la bonne période vous pouvez les
mettre en commentaire ça pourra enrichir
le débat mais à ma connaissance je crois
pas qu'ils ont des masses je ne crois
pas qu'il y en ait des masses peut-être
au brésil voilà peut-être au brésil mais
si nombreux donc voilà il ya du débat
mais faut voir aussi à pas salir le
débat avec des choses qui ont rien à y
faire
en gros c'est ça que je veux dire il ya
effectivement de quoi débattre sur cette
reconstitution mais voilà déjà commencé
par nettoyer le fait que la
reconstitution de 2014 ce n'est pas le
lot type
enfin ce n'est pas le néo type et le néo
type n'est pas la reconstitution de 2014
les deux sont deux choses totalement
séparés on ne peut pas cracher sur
ibrahim et al 2001 juste en crachant sur
la publication de sur la reconstitution
de 2014 qui est celle là ce qui est fait
dans ibrahim étals 2020 n'est basée que
sur le nez au type est donc c'est au
moins au niveau du fossile c'est plutôt
propre
voilà après si vous voulez discuter des
proportions de spinosaurus effectivement
il ya de quoi discuter ça je suis
d'accord il ya du débat
j'étais le premier à dire que les jambes
étaient beaucoup trop courte et que les
bras était beaucoup trop mais bon bah
après c'est une hypothèse quoi c'est une
hypothèse c'est est stable mais il faut
savoir que le côté enfin le l'adaptation
au mode de vie semi-aquatique de
spinosaurus ne tient pas qu'à ça voilà
donc maintenant dire maintenant que
spinosaurus n'était pas semi-aquatique
faut arriver à dire que faut arriver du
cou a expliqué pourquoi sa queue et si
et si bizarrement pourquoi les vertèbres
de sa queue sont si bizarrement articulé
faudrait arriver à expliquer pourquoi
ces eaux sont hyper dense faudrait
arriver à expliquer pourquoi sashimis
isotopique
reflète a mis un mode de vie aquatique
faudrait expliquer faudrait expliquer
autrement pas mal de choses quoi donc
bon ces deux c'est là qu'on en est c'est
là qu'on se tient et fit y ait
effectivement après la posture bipèdes
ou quadrupèdes de toute façon c'est des
choses qui ne peuvent être démontrés que
par des empreintes 1
dans l'absolu il n'y a pas grand chose
ou par un squelette complet qui aurait
cette fois les bonnes proportions deux
bras et deux jambes mais ça ça c'est
déjà assez exceptionnel qu'ils aient
retrouvé des morceaux d'os d'un
dinosaure articulé dans les quelques m
sachant que 98 % de ce que tu retrouves
dans les calmes et kmkm c'est en miettes
et que même si vous trouvez même si
quelqu'un trouve un truc articulé il est
possible que ce quelqu'un soit un
revendeur de fossiles qui du coup le
désarticule pour en vendre plus de rock
voilà c'est pas c'est pas gagner gagner
c'est bien qu'ils aient quelqu'un
maintenant qui regarde voilà on va dire
ça comme ça
donc voila c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]